Elton John is retiring from touring but
Alicia Keys is back with a vengeance on
the voice and we've got the scoop on her
collaboration with Justin Timberlake it
is the end of the yellow brick road for
Elton John I know this word gets thrown
around a lot especially by me but this
man is an icon and the iconic rock star
is retiring from touring I love my boys
I hate being away from them and I've had
so many wonderful memories from touring
I've done over 4,000 shows and I loved
them and I love performing but I love my
son's more but don't expect the 70 year
old who is worth an estimated 500
million dollars to go out quietly
Elton will bid farewell with one last
world tour his farewell yellow brick
road tour will kick off in September and
stretch over three years this is the
last hurrah
I'm nothing to do that you've got to go
around and say to all the continents and
say this is it goodbye thank you very
much I want you to see the best shows
ever done now listen I'm a huge fan of
the Rocket Man so I'm a little bit in
denial and as et has seen over the years
Elton does have a history of teasing and
Edie to life on the road I mean I said I
said in 1977 I think I was gonna retire
in Wembley in London and of course I
didn't but I was feeling the pressure
then and I was but on the other hand I
didn't want to take two or three years
often people forget about who I was
still you was pretty adamant out of
press conference today that this is it
you know I'm not gonna be one of these
people says I'm gonna do a world tour
and then I'm retiring I'm not sure even
though I like wearing her clothes
which reminds me and true Elton John
fashion Gucci will be designing all of
his looks for his last tour so you know
he's about to turn up all shiny
shimmering and splendid all right guys
speaking of splendid joining me now is
our senior music editor sophie scholl AC
so Elton John can you believe it that is
a very long time to say goodbye three
years so I think we have some time to
wrap our heads all right but you're
actually here to talk about another
music superstar miss Alicia key
yes that is right
Leisha is returning to the voice as a
coach this season her guest mentor is
Shawn Mendes and let me tell you t make
a is taking no prisoners and they're
coming for reigning champ Blake Shelton
since you started on the show do you
feel like Gwen has made Blake mellow out
a little bit with the competitiveness no
no one can save him he's unstable he's
on the dark side he's slightly guys he's
crazy right up until the end like it's
at the end that he starts to become like
the secret villain who's trying to win
it all yes it's true you can see it in
the face in the eyes and we get along so
well and and you know he was just so
crushed that I beat him so thoroughly
when I did and I you know I hope to be
able to experience that again I have to
come back and like put him in his place
yeah tell me a little bit about the girl
power vibe between you and Kelly and I'm
all about the girl power and you know
the whole world is about girl power
because as we see clearly we need us
badly to make sure that power is intact
so the world can be safe
she's such a magnificent what a crazy
amazing beautiful voice you know what I
mean and in person you know plus she's
kind of silly like me so I think we
really get along and and in just a
supernatural way but yes I love it
Alecia I got asked about JT oh that's
right we've been wanting to do a song
together for a minute and I remember
even we you know we've done some
songwriting together and everything like
that and and there's more to come
because we're we have so much synergy
you know he I love his I love how he
creates you know he's very very very
passionate about what he does he's
really inside himself and inside of the
music and it's just it's just like me so
it's it's it's it's so fresh that we
have this song together on his album
that's coming which is crazy yeah what
can you tell you I love this record man
I really feel like he's every time he
comes I feel like he finds a new place
of himself you know and I love the way
he just like slightly pushes the
boundary a little bit more to jessica
transit yeah
and it's this the best way to be so I'm
excited for him y'all gonna love this
record here for a beautiful that
unleashes collaboration with Justin
Timberlake is featured on his new album
man of the wood now someone else on that
album is JT's buddy Chris Stapleton I
know you're a fan absolutely doesn't
actually tweeted a little snippet of the
video for their collaborations say
something which drops tomorrow thank
goodness at 9 a.m. Pacific 12:00 p.m.
Eastern and get this you guys Stapleton
will also be performing at the Grammys
on Sunday they just announced that today
and also hitting the Grammy stage is
steep now postal the most deems Corden
is back for round 2 listen I'm just glad
he recovered from falling down the
stairs last year yeah he still got some
nerves but Corden says the night is not
about him it's about the performances
Kendrick I think I haven't seen it yet
because we haven't started rehearsing
but I've seen a sort of outline of what
it is and if it's as good as it is in my
head it's gonna be amazing I think it's
gonna be incredible and is Lady Gaga's
performing cash and yet good Kesha and
childish gambino and Sam Smith and
there's just some really wonderful
moments I think listen the Grammys
always turn out to be some of the most
epic performances I cannot wait to see
what Chris Stapleton have in the story
he always brings it also curious though
to see if pink is gonna be scaling any
buildings for her performance something
tells me that's probably gonna happen
but I'm holding out for jay-z and
Beyonce to do family feud now that has
neither been confirmed nor denied but
let me tell you guys Sophie and I are on
the case make sure you guys tune into
our live Grammys preview at UT now on
Twitter or on e t--'s youtube channel
that's going down Friday at 10 a.m.
Pacific all right thanks so much for
hanging out so thanks for watching we'll
see you tomorrow bye
[Music]